Wow!
Hello, everybody.
Wait, let me put up my lo-fi.
I have, like, 20 tabs up right now.
Give me a sec.
Alright, here you go.
Lo-fi!
Yay!
Now we're actually comfy.
Let's go.
Oh, today was a very long day today.
We're so close to 700k!
I don't know if we're getting it at the end of the stream,
but I just thought it'd be nice to have it there.
you know it'll just be nice to have the counter there nice
yeah but what a long exhausting day we had today we yeah we
we sort of we sort of low key overdid it today in terms of
streaming I don't know what it is about Overwatch something
about Overwatch just makes me go like crazy oh Yeah, I
didn't realize you guys know like the alpha test for Marvel
rivals For for Marvel rivals is actually like Um, it's it
it's coming out next week.
I think I think it's next week right.
Yeah, it's coming on Friday the alpha test I actually didn't
realize that That's crazy.
I noticed I just saw I saw like because I was like I made
the joke about like oh This is gonna be like Marvel rivals
waiting room by the way fucking shitty name
It's a really bad name.
I'll admit.
Marvel Rivals.
It just doesn't...
I think it's because, like, it just doesn't roll off the
tongue very well.
Marvel Rivals.
It feels like a tongue twister, you know?
Marvel Rivals, Marvel Rivals.
It just feels like...
It feels like a fucking tongue twister.
Not like, you know, Apex Legends, Overwatch, Fortnite.
Like, these are things that roll off your tongue very
easily.
a terrible name for for it's such a terrible name for for a
for a game title um it just sounds really me i wish it was a
different name uh but i signed up i i signed up for like the
alpha test but it says like there i was reading it up and it
said that they're planning on taking in 30 000 people uh 30
000 people uh for the alpha test so like if any you know if
any If anybody has any connections to...
All I'm saying is that if anybody has any connections to
NetEase or like the developers of Marvel Rivals, and you
know, you guys could like sneak me in so like I can, you
know, I can do like a playthrough test, you know?
I can give you guys content, publicity!
I could give you publicity chat!
guys guys any any Marvel rival devs in chat I can come on my
I sign up
Deadpool they give us super chat thank you thank you there
was no toxicity in Overwatch just like there's no war
embossing say thank you super chat thank you thank you oh my
god um I had a game it was actually fucking crazy it was oh
he was so oh shit i had it i had a game where there was a
there was a reaper one trick on the enemy team and he was
really fucking bad so then like i think like one of our
teammates called him out and was like because like the the
mercy player on the enemy team was like this was off stream
the mercy play on the enemy team was like report our reaper
he's trolling and then the reaper was like no report our
mercy she's like pistiling from spawn and one of our one of
the teammates on my team was like bro not gonna lie you're
pretty you're not gonna lie you're a pretty bad player like
that's the reaper one trick and he was like like the person
on my team was like, you know, we should all report the
like, he was like in the all chat, you know, we should
report you for being a terrible player.
And then and then, okay, and then it escalated because the
teammate, my teammate was like, you should kill him.
I was like, I got, I was like,
Wiggly!
And then the enemy Reaper straight up dropped a gamer word.
Chat!
Holy shit And then the The Reaper 1 drink Straight up was
like Gamer Word Everyone
is all chapped But straight up was like Whoa Like both were
bad But one was worse than the other Because I can't say the
gamer word And so obviously I reported the gamer word Reaper
one trick and I got I got the report be like Thank you for
reporting on this person.
We have banned them And you know, you know, they're so used
to they're so used to dropping that shit Because they knew
exactly how to censor that word in a way that it showed up
in chat once but twice because usually it would be censored
in asterix but this guy knew exactly how to type it so that
it would show up and we could see exactly what that word was
and all of us were just like whoa it was fucking crazy uh
all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you super chat thank you thank you follow me thank you
the super chat thank you thank you most tamed overwatch
conversation thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you i think you the super chat thank you thank you yeah so
overwatch is like it's a very it's a very interesting game
but yeah i'm i i hope i get into uh red thank you with super
chat thank you thank you i hope i get into the alpha test
because i would love to try it out um it'll be very exciting
but yeah next week is to be i know i said next week was
supposed to be the rest week but next week is going to be a
very interesting week for me it's it's gonna uh yes we'll
see in the schedule soon of why why it'll be a very
interesting week for me but it's it's a lot it's a lot of
stuff i still haven't figured out figured out my party
animals team as well i was supposed to figure out by but I
asked I'm gonna give them the I'm gonna figure it out
tomorrow so we'll see it's supposed to be today but then
maybe they'll let me wait until tomorrow Zaka thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you congrats on master's joke
you thank you for the super chat thank you thank you delete
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy at
least elimination day joke you was that me you the super
chat thank you thank you um I'm also like okay also by the
way has Should I, like, resize my stuff smaller for
Overwatch streams?
I noticed, like, am I too big on the screen, guys?
Do you think I should be smaller?
I was worried that I'd cover up too much of the gameplay.
So if I ever do another Overwatch stream, Zeku, thank you
for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I like big, dokey.
No, bigger.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hmm.
Full body left side.
You won't be able to see the HP on the left side.
Yeah, that head is huge.
That's where my brain goes.
Yeah, I'll make it a little.
I'll make it a little bit smaller.
I don't know if I do ever do an Overwatch stream.
Again, maybe I'll just do like a stream or just play and
just get top 500.
And that's it.
I don't have no plans on ending top 500.
Because the reward system for Overwatch.
For Overwatch.
It's just not, it's just not, like, something I care.
The rankings were really fun.
Don't get lost.
Thank you, guys, for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I just played to have fun.
I don't really care about rank anymore.
I just think, like, I just think, like, the reward.
If the rewards were worth it, I'd definitely play more.
But the rewards was 100% not worth it at all.
It was just, it just was like, it's not.
It's like it's like some fucking What was it?
It was it's like the tagline that lasts for one season Like
I don't care.
I don't care about that I don't care about if it was forever
like the icon is praised Then I care a little bit more But
the fact that it's just like a tagline that only lasts for
one season is just not worth it Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want Doki so big We can see the tomato inside.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you let's see um one yeah it's only the tagline so
when you get top 500 in Overwatch 2 uh you get like this
tagline that just says top 500 challenger or something that
like shows people that you ended in top 500 but it you lose
it after one season so they go away and that's it that's it
I was like I don't care I don't care if it goes away like
what's the what the fuck's the point you know um so like i
don't mind just touching top 500 on stream because usually
in the past i never stream my rank sessions because when i
get like super serious or like barely when i get super
serious in rank i don't stream my rank sessions because i
cannot like you know i i talk to you guys and play at the
same time so you know damn well i am not focused at all when
am i playing on
but um when i play off stream i play off stream of course
i'm like super focused and i actually like pay attention to
my surroundings and everything and he plans on more apex
algs got me i haven't watched algs uh this season i honestly
i think if i asked for like drops on my twitch account they
would give me to me but like i i honestly like i usually
watch during uh i i watch for like the finals like the
finals finalists this is like what is it called it's uh
split one so i'm not like as like um also i haven't done a
watch along of it so uh and like i'm honestly like uh i'm
just waiting for i'm just waiting for like the new update
because for the new uh legend and everything um only thing
in dokey's head is a white Yeah, no thought head empty.
I came here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So if you're a tomato and thief, doesn't that make you a
kleptomato?
Grats on Masters, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Splatoon 3.
No, Splatoon has made me the most toxic person ever.
Because in Splatoon, in Splatoon, you can't talk to anybody.
So you can't verbalize your hatred for your teammates.
so Splatoon has been like the game that made me like the
most toxic I can ever be in rank because and it's also like
really tilting because it's on Nintendo it's on Nintendo
servers and Nintendo is not great with you know with latency
and stuff and because of that like connections are fucking
terrible as well and like so when DCs it's just loseable and
you don't even get like rank protection or anything and I I
just fucking hate Nintendo servers like I just don't
understand why why the latency can be so bad I don't
understand like you have so much money what do you do with
your money like thank you for the magenta soup thank you
thank you I was watching your Overwatch stream on my for my
TV at work today something I got stuck doing paperwork so
you can cover as much of the
Thank you.
I was very toxic.
I would actually, like, slam, slam things if I lose.
And, like, I would, oh, my God.
I was, it was so bad.
It was so bad for Splatoon.
And the player base for, like, Splatoon is also, like, not
that high.
Like, you would think, like, Overwatch player base is pretty
bad.
But Splatoon player base is absolutely terrible.
His majority of the players are in Japan.
The NA players aren't like Yeah
Never It's all in Asia So like the connection is like Even
more terrible But like they'll never Nintendo It's just too
big to fail I don't know why we always Go back to Nintendo
But It doesn't matter what they do The moment they release
something remotely, nostalgia bait, people just forget
everything.
If Nintendo one day does something so terrible that, like,
people actually start boycotting, all they have to do is
just release the new Smash Bros.
or a new Zelda game.
That's really it.
Well, it's Nintendo.
They don't need to do anything.
everything is freaking i okay someone says everything is
forgiving by the next direct i i'm so sad i miss e3 i miss i
miss e3 e3 was so fucking hyped i love all the i love i wish
we could just why i wish i i wish e3 was still going on so
we can do like watchalongs of e3 i miss Those were so
fucking hyped.
And even if like, some of them were like, yeah, but the
recent shows were so cringe.
That's the best part when it's cringe and you can make fun
of it.
Like Summer Game Fest, it's not the same.
It's not the same.
Even the booths were so good too.
The booths on E3 presentations were so good as well.
It's just not the same.
cringe was amazing exactly even with the but then they were
like what about the gamer awards the gamer words oh my god
bro the gamer awards is not it's just it's just not it's
just trailers it's just game trailers there's no like
performances or anything other than the music performances
and stuff not every game company is doing their own fucking
direct because nintendo did it first I'm gonna say the
Nintendo direct is so boring
it's not it's not hype anymore it's so boring it's remember
when like wait it was a robot chicken oh my god remember
when like Nintendo did the robot chicken thing was that e3
or was that like a different one that what shit was so funny
it was so good too and and now like it directs your soul
yeah e3 2013 bro for those who never didn't realize um e3
did uh like nintendo back when nintendo still participated
in e3 uh they did like a robot chicken parody i felt like
honestly not gonna lie i feel like nintendo was much more
chill back then compared to now I think compared to now
they're definitely more harsh and strict with things oh yeah
the Muppets too the Muppets one they're really good at they
were so good at publicity back then um I don't know what
happened I feel like now they're like much more strict red
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you not just
reggie but like other stuff too salute i mean it makes sense
because the guy is run it's run by the nintendo america is
run by the guy named bowser right yeah yuata son too i feel
like they were much more chill back then compared to now um
i'm trying to like remember like Yeah, I don't, I'm not like
a huge fan of, I'm not a huge fan of like game companies
doing, of game companies doing like, uh, presentation, like
their own presentations because it feels less hype and
boring.
I'm not hype about game releases these days, especially like
when like everybody just like leaks what they're going to
release and stuff.
and usually like like you don't because everything gets
leaked now that like you don't get hyped over a game release
when it just shows up out of nowhere you know like world
premieres and stuff like when like you like it's just not
nothing was ever said about the certain game and it's
something you find out on e3 alone and everyone's like wow
now now now you know everything that's gonna uh nicola think
of a super chat thank you thank you uh came here i think you
was super chat thank you thank you nothing will ever top
giant enemy crap my body is ready and ridge racer i think it
was super chat thank you thank you um times were simpler
yeah everything was so much more simpler back then now i
feel like now games are game releases are not as hyped
anymore i don't know i mean we do have like a lot of indie
games and stuff um Indie games are now more popular than
like AAA games and everything because like they get to make
whatever they want to make and they're not governed by the
corporate executive board that was like, no, you should
change that and this.
So a lot of indie game devs are just doing whatever the fuck
they want and not having to worry about trying to fit into
whatever the exec wants.
Indie games don't really make multiplayer FPS games
Where are the developers making games for me For me I don't
wanna wanna play single player games I wanna play
multiplayer FPS games that I can solo queue so I don't have
to look for collab partners right thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it's just all we have is just apex
and overwatch
I was like I was gonna say oh yeah do you guys hear about
hell divers too fucking rest in peace that game died it's
too late they can't do anything to save they can't they
can't do anything to to save the game now lucky for them
lucky for them EDF is coming out too so yeah it's already
over the moment oh what happened basically they made you
required to have a PlayStation account to link your
PlayStation account to Hell Divers 2 even though it's on
Steam.
People don't like that because there's extra steps.
Wait, Steam is actually getting refunds to people?
Oh, thank God, Valve.
Thank God, Gabe.
Gabe always knows what's... Gabe has to have like the
fucking best like publicity PR team in the fucking world,
because he's a true gamer.
Gabe is a real fucking gamer, and I'll be so sad if Valve
ever goes, gets on the stock market, and gets an executive
board, because that's when everything will go downhill.
Deadfoot, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Don't shoot my baby like this.
They can still walk it back.
Oh, somebody's coping.
Look at that poor fool coping that they can return from this
you know okay gamers do forget but like the thing about
gamers is that you have to have a big enough reputation you
have to have something that would make gamers want to come
back to you but like i'm gonna say hell damage too i don't
like you gotta be like big enough like nintendo to be able
to recover from this like and and hell damage too does not
Does not have that reputation, unfortunately.
I don't think Helldivish 2 is...
The thing is, the thing is, the only way, the only way I
see, like, Helldivish 2 coming back from this is, is if, um,
is if Sony makes an apology.
And I don't think Sony is going to make an apology.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Truly the best PR strategy.
Do nothing and watch other companies make mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think they're gonna apologize.
Let's see, Razi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, I think it's a way a lot because they actually have
redeeming features.
Someone didn't look at the news recently.
I still love Nintendo, though.
Like, it's, it's a, because I still I'm just a consumer.
I'm just a consumer that's stuck in the that's stuck because
the properties they own are just too good to leave
um uh yeah i do miss like miss e3 i think it's just like i
think like watching doing watchalongs of like uh like you
know like game announcements and game news just isn't the
same just isn't the same the memes are not as good too I
think it's the memes the memes that come out of game
announcement are just not good They're just so boring that
people can't make memes out of it The only memes we got out
of like game announcements were Were the fucking um, what
was it?
Um, the one with a kid fucking Uh, what's the word?
The kid just showed a random kid just showed out of nowhere
just And I see crashes, the game awards.
That was, like, the only meme that came out of the game
awards.
Quentin, thank you for the five.
Give the ships thank you.
Thank you.
Swibbly.
Sony apology.
We're sorry you felt this way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Never.
I don't even want to think about what happened.
The game goes.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Oh, yeah.
I'm trying to, like...
are some good games coming out too by the way guys guys you
guys know what can what where some of the what some of some
good games are coming out soon i can't even i don't even i
can't even like think of any good games coming out recently
edf other than edf edf um stock oh silk song suck Copium
I mean like the next couple of months guys the next couple
of months I guess someone was like so son copium it's not
it's not cop oh Hades too I'm so sad I didn't get into the
beta test I wanted to get into the beta test for Hades too
and do like a sneak peak stream but like I couldn't I
couldn't get into I couldn't get into the beta test but i
wanted to try it out on stream stellar blade yeah but that's
already out dad think of the super chat thing you think is
system shock 2 and has additions forever on the radar thank
you the super chat thank you thank you overwatch 3 yeah i
know wukon's coming out but that's like um like quarter four
what was it it's at uh the end of the uh the end of the
quarter or something um it's gonna be a while before it's
gonna be a while before uh before it comes out
you know titan fall three i'm coping i don't know i can't
think of like any um any good games that are gonna be coming
out soon chat like how's people more like elder ring god
elder ring dlc guys i haven't played elder ring dragon ball
z sparkling z Is that a...
Is that a...
Okay, Dragon Ball Z Sparkling Zero.
Is that a fighting game?
Or an adventure game?
For Dragon Ball Z?
Because that's basically the majority of Dragon Ball Z
games.
Oh, it is.
Okay.
I almost hit.
I wish...
I said it before.
in the sandland playthrough but i wish i really do wish they
make other types of adaptations of anime games that's not
just fighting games there's so much lore to it you know why
you know why it's because they need to get this shit out
fast before like animate the anime series dies like that's
the thing they're so scared it's the easiest yeah it's one
of the easiest you're so scared that the hype is gonna die
out um that hype is gonna die out that they always make like
fucking fighting i'm not talking about dragon ball z because
it makes sense dragon ball z uh fighting games makes sense
but there's like games that just doesn't fucking make sense
it just it just doesn't make sense and it's then they're
like sometimes they're fucking terrible too i don't i don't
i get And it's like, it's because it's easy to make and it's
like, it's cheaper.
And it's also like, you don't want to get in on the hype
before it's over.
And, uh, and like there's so many, it's crazy.
The thing I hate about like how anime series, anime series
goes is that they're so scared about losing hype that like
some of the anime shows don't even have time to like sink
in.
for people that by the next season like the next like it was
like oh winter spring fall summer rose out like it's
forgetting like people forget about it there's so many
animas that are releasing almost every season that like it's
so hard for any show to even like build an audience and i
hate it like every season like 40 plus animas get released
it's so competitive it's all hype based yeah the moment the
season of it ends people forget about it it's over like like
i hate it because it doesn't even build up the the fan base
of like it doesn't build up the fan base of people yeah the
market saturations and stuff like that there's so many types
of animas like that unless you're probably like the big
fucking four or something um in blocks thank you the super
chat thank you thank you hi doki don't know about the other
dragoons but my biggest recent game is like a dragon besides
uh fun thank you super chat thank you thank you um i don't
i've never played any of the yakuza games but they're so so
long i know because like my dad played the yakuza games and
um and like it took him fucking i don't even know if he beat
it it took him fucking forever he doesn't play it anymore so
i assume he beat it but it's a very very long game um mb
thank you for super chat thank you thank you an adventure
game thank you thank you 16 bit frost thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you doki i need another 30 for
frost punk punk 2 and possibly dragon ball z and stock 2 and
uh more to come thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you uh cucumber thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you very much thank you for the magenta soup thank you thank
you i can't wait for the visual novel crossover anime
fighter featuring school days clan ad and doki doki
literature club thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um I just think like uh I just feel like I feel like I
feel like people really should slow down with the anime
releases like just space them out more because there's
apparently I like I don't watch a lot of anime um because I
don't have time to read subtitles while uh I don't have time
to read subtitles while playing um while doing work or
playing something so I don't watch a lot of anime but I've
always heard how how like people would be like oh man this
anime show was so underrated and people already forgot about
it and someone was like bro when that was this ad when X
insert X anime got released um it was like that one of the
most hype anime is out there but people already forgot about
it because there's so many anime is that's being released
almost every season that like um even really good ones get
like like forgotten and stuff like i feel like a lot of
people already forgot about what was it the the one with all
the animals as like students students or something god
what's that anime called i already forgot
remember when like um i got reincarnated as a slime that
shit was like one of the biggest show anime yeah beast stars
i feel like beast stars is already people already forgot
about beast stars but when that anime came out so many
people were like so hyped about it and like like talked
about it all everywhere and then like it died out and then
there was what was it and then there was that fucking other
anime we've reincarnated as a slime no one really talks
about that anymore slime is literally airing right now yeah
but no one talks about it like the time when it first came
out and there was that other one with the spider remember
that's little that reincarnated as a spider that one no one
talks about it anymore because after the first season unless
you're like big big
so it's like i did not even know there was a new season
and then but we don't talk about one punch man one punch man
like fucking like shot itself in the foot like that's on
them and then did you guys know i don't even know if it came
up blue exorcist oh my god all i'm saying that when blue
exorcist first came up that was not gonna lie i feel like
blue exorcist was like one of the fujo bait animas out there
like every bro everybody loved that shit like i remember
and that was the show and then when it ended nobody cared
that was and now everybody nobody cared after after it ended
and stuff and and then apparently apparently it's getting a
new season it's getting isn't it getting it's getting a new
season right or did it aired or did it did it already aired
did it already aired like yeah they made it i saw making up
fake shows yeah no it is airing nobody cares now no one
talks about blue exorcist even though like it was one of the
fucking shows of of like um the show of the season and now
it has a new season it got a revival and people were like we
are like oh my god nobody cares oh yeah and then there's
free holy no if i say blue exorcist was fujo bait fucking
free was fujo bait as hell because like at least yuri on ice
like it's implied that they got together free they're just
all really really good friends like
Like, Yuri and I, at least it's implied, but free was just,
we're just homies.
But, like, people can dream.
Yeah, friends.
They were dating in my heart.
They're just best buds.
Free is, and they were roommates.
The anime.
They're just really, really good friends and roommates.
I don't know what you're implying.
and get married in yuri on ice yeah and apparently they oh
my gosh i don't know if you guys heard about the controversy
of uh yuri on ice but like they recently canceled the movie
like officially canceled the movie and like some fucking i
saw like people were like you know reacting very negatively
about it because like yuri on ice is like um is like was has
a very like deep now it's like has a cult following at that
point because it's been like forever since they made new
content for it and like apparently like remember i was
reading on twitter because it was trending on twitter and
people were saying like people were like oh um there's some
behind the scenes shenanigans i saw why yuri on ice was
cancelled and i was like what the fuck is going on people
were like the director of some behind the scenes shenanigans
as to why we never got Yuri on ice the movie the
conspiracies yeah the conspiracies um um there were black
butter air oh yeah they fucking remade black butter or the
new season I don't know Can you think of the super chat?
Thinking they ain't care.
No one cares.
It's actually crazy.
And no one really, like, talked about the Black Butler shit
too.
There's just so many things that, like, like, like, there's
so many animas and stuff that comes out.
Wait, Beastars was the anime?
I thought it was an empty shark.
I'll think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, they did.
They aired a, they aired a new anime for Black Butler.
Um...
But people just glossed over it.
It's just, every season, only one or two animas are like the
biggest things ever.
And if you're not, and they fit the two anime, like the
biggest seat for like, oh, like summer anime.
The summer anime is insert anime here.
And there can only be two, I feel like.
I feel like there can only be two.
And then even though there's like other animas that might be
really, really fucking good.
of two then it's over
it's people don't care
it's just it's just forgotten it could be like really really
fucking good too but it doesn't matter they already met
their quota of two good atomies oh
there's only a yeah there's only a limited amount of
attention that goes around and oh my gosh i tried i tried to
watch oshinoko i couldn't i watched like two episodes and i
got depressed because i was like this is too real i couldn't
keep watching i had so sad
Oh yeah, they did a reboot of Shaman King too They did a
reboot of Shaman.
There's so many fucking reboots.
Oh my gosh, I hate it.
Anime is nostalgia baiting now.
It's nostalgia baiting.
I thought we could get away.
It was nostalgia bait.
Express, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy May the 4th and Revenge of the 5th from Australia,
Doki.
Is there any clone trooper character squad lesion color
patterns that you like is your favorite thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i don't know about clone
troopers but i want to be a sift lord because at least sift
lords i remember you guys told me when we were playing that
star wars game you guys were like uh uh when if you are a
jedi you have to be pure and then when you guys told me like
pure i didn't i i was like oh okay that makes sense because
yeah i'd be like you know a good person and you guys like no
you can't even have a family i was like oh my god and it
like registered like all jedas are technically virgins i was
like yeah they can't not even like a little they can't even
feel love it's crazy they're actual wizards they can't even
feel love i was like Holy shit, bro.
It literally, like, not my Christian-friendly channel.
Except for that one guy who's, like, whose race that needed
to be repopulated.
So they gave him the one exception.
And even then, he has to, like, not love his family.
Which is so fucked up to think about.
Like, voluntarily sell a bit.
Yeah, you can't have any attachment.
Why the fuck would you be a Jedi?
Simplers are cooler.
this voice sounds so much cooler because of that uh fate
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you i mean they
can continue the bloodline jedi's can't i hope spice and
wolf does the opposite since no one cared when they
originally aired and then people love this so maybe the
remake people will care from the start maybe i'm just gonna
sit and cope now thank you for the akasupa thank you thank
you but they're evil joki so but they're rich though and
they can bang
how can they continue the bloodline how can they get the
ladies they get the ladies um yeah if evil while hard
exactly.
I just think, but yeah, that's my rant about anime.
Even though I don't watch a lot of anime in general, I just
think it's dumb that a lot of really, really well-animated
anime shows are forgotten because there's always, there's
just too many being released and there's always a quota.
It's like, if there's more than two good animas being
released, the third plus, third, four, fifth, sixth good
anime will not be noticed because people don't care enough.
a farm welcome back anton thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you star wars romance fan fix aren't canon because
kudis countered the inquirions thank you the super chat
thank you thank you um other things do i want to talk about
i also don't like how i i hate okay i hate binging i hate
shows that are supposed to be bingeable um i think like
series that you can binge in one sitting has killed our love
for like shows because our because like we forget about them
after it's over like I think like binging shows is such a
bad concept because uh uh because like you know you consume
everything in one go that there's no hype going yeah it
kills the hype i honestly think it kills um it kills the
hype instantly for like shows and i really hate that culture
in general now because like some really really good shows
get forgotten so easily that's so hard to build any fan base
in general um if it's like really good um and i think that's
like one of the worst things right now with the binging con
culture uh by size thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you you're using your top 500 to count today me a
question i want to ask what do you consider your greatest
achievement video games is getting us sponsored by my
favorite games is like what i think my greatest achievement
video games because i spent so much like money and time
playing this game and then when i get sponsored by them
they're paying me so in the end like i made back the money i
spent on that game
and so i i think that's like my i think that's like my
greatest achievement because it's like it's like i get paid
back you know like the money just comes back and more uh to
me thank you for the 10 gifted ships thank you thank you uh
yeah the cash back strats exactly speaking of cash back
strats have you guys heard about my fortnite code uh you can
use my fortnite creator code that dokeybird uh whenever you
purchase anything on fortnite so um so like you know so like
you know you're already gonna purchase something anyway you
know you're already gonna purchase something so you might as
well like you know use the creator code the infinite money
glitch oh my god okay so i don't remember who i was having
this conversation with i think i was like talking to like a
fortnight creator and like they can literally oh when
fortnight was like when they were like at the peak of
fortnight content creation like as a fortnight streamer they
literally made like i think like $500,000 per month of the
fortnight creator code at its peak i was like half a million
a fortnite creator code back when fortnite was at its
fucking peak i don't remember who the streamer was it was
not ninja just so you guys know it was not ninja it was not
ninjas i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure if it was ninja it'll
be a million dollars a million a million per month if it was
ninja but like it was some fucking fortnite creator like a
fortnight streamer years ago years ago they could like
passively make 500 g's per month and i was like that is
fucking insane like oh my god no wonder they put stream at
fortnight every day bro that shit that shit makes bank holy
shit yeah passive income because there's a lot of little
kids using their mama and papa's credit cards to buy
fortnight skins and that shit says that shit like makes so
much money guys I'm gonna well the fortnite the fortnite
hype is over so I'm sorry to say but like it's too late now
it's too late to start now guys it is it is it's actually
crazy to be able to make that much off of like one fucking
month oh my god that fortnite hype is over that's why guys
that's why i need them to quickly come out with a new
massive multiplayer game so i can get good really cat so i
can get really really good at it and then become the next
ninja of that game and then pray to god they have a creator
code so i can make 500 guys that's why i'm begging for
another another like multiplayer FPS game or TPS I'll even
take TPS guys I'll even take TPS I'm willing to settle so I
could be the next ninja or tens or shroud and it makes so
much fucking content of that one game and I'll be the VTuber
that plays that's really good at this one game
I'll be I'll even communicate I'll even do callouts in
Marvel I swear if Marvel rivals becomes the next I please
okay honestly I don't not gonna lie though I don't think
Marvel rivals will um I honestly I don't know I mean it has
potential but like I've stopped I've stopped like hoping and
I've
I'm sorry, but I've stopped believing
It seems like a quick cash grab Our only hope is if, like,
what's the company?
What's the game company that makes Valorant and League
again?
What are they called again?
Riot, my only hope is if Riot makes a Battle Royale Or a
team-based shooter because they'll do everything they can to
pump millions of dollars into the game to make it work we
all thought csgo 2 would save us but csgo 2 practically
killed csgo we all thought the finals would be the next hype
but then it died so fast toky no please riot games make
battle royale or a multiplayer or a fucking team-based
shooter please riot is doing major no they're making a
fighting game their next step is a team-based shooter or
battle royale no i missed the battle royale genre i missed
it so much i remember we used to rule the world Now we're
just like Starcraft.
Now we're just like...
Now we're just like strategic games.
Finding games are trending now.
I miss when PUBG was the way it is now.
There's just too many hackers in PUBG.
Peter, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
uh guess the files met its finale thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it's the fighting game era no i
only mean fighting games are always super popular i used to
i mean i watch evo quite often i watch it on and off i used
to i don't i don't know actually i haven't watched evo in
like three years two years in two years because i never had
the time but like you know two to three years but they're
like when i had the time i would watch evo but usually the
finals because like that was like the most hype um the evil
finals um but uh evil like fighting games have always been
popular because they have such a diehard fan base and like
the thing about like fighting games is i mean it's similar
with like shooters where like aim can translate to any type
of game and like usually fighting game fighting game players
like esports players they can like they can transfer their
skills to like different types of fighting games so because
like the combos are usually like not like that not similar
in a way but you can transfer like how like different types
of like you can transfer it easily to different types of
fighting games and that's why like uh i know like esport
pros in fighting game genres would be like specialist they
won't be like specialists in one game they would like they
would be they would like know how to play and also win uh
win uh competitions and tournaments in different types of
games within fighting games um so they don't have to be like
just like oh they're only specialized in this one game they
can like literally enter so many different games um as a
player uh and yeah the it transfers from game to it easily
transfers from game to games yeah like justin wand and sonic
fox yeah yeah that's what i was like thinking about too so i
don't see like fighting games as like i feel like they've
always been popular i don't think they're like oh they're
like it's a new rise it's a new trend now i think they've
always been pretty popular um because of evo uh sleepy ash
thank you
I always wish there was like I was I wish I can adapt
I wish I can adapt
my genre is dying what do I do adapt or die but what if I'm
too slow to adapt
Um, um, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
It's been an hour already?
Holy shit.
I can talk for so long.
I really am a yapper.
The learning curve is too steep.
I think it's because, like, I mean, oh my gosh, there's so
much stuff to do.
There's just so much stuff to do.
It's hard to make time these days to, like, do stuff so um
so like that's like one of my biggest issues it's just hard
to make time to learn new video games and stuff and um
there's a lot to learn like i had like friends that are like
you should learn league that's like bro by the time i get
good at league like league people have been playing league
for fucking 10 plus years like that's just impossible
you should not like i also like i don't like mobas i really
i really don't like mobas and there's too many characters in
league too and then they'd be like but like oh you should
learn league you might like it i'm like bro by the time i
even like figure out how to fucking play league the game
would have moved on the game people would be like people who
were like at my level when I started would be like 50 times
better than me do not learn league it's a not successful you
can see we're chatting like thank you also like it's such a
money pit same with Riot same with Valorant people always
complain about skins and like currency prices for like other
games apex and overwatch but league and valorant is the
biggest money pit ever when it comes to skins because they
already set the grounds on like the default of how expensive
they are that like people don't complain these were all
sheep because we're like oh that was the default anyway so
it's fine like knife skins being fucking 40 dollars like
what the fuck is that bullshit like
like i'm just being like oh my god but like an overwatch
skin would be like maybe like five to ten dollars like a
fucking knife in valorant it would be so goddamn expensive
and people will buy multiple skins of that too like multiple
cosmetics from that and it's actually i feel like i like i
don't want to say that But like, Fortnite skins are funny.
The thing of...
The thing is, I buy Fortnite skins for the crossovers.
But Valorant is like purely like cosmetics.
Like, like the design from the store itself.
Like, I buy Fortnite skins because I don't want to be
fucking Vegeta in Fortnite.
Like, I want to be Peter Griffin in Fortnite.
Like, it's funny.
It's just...
It's just funny.
And still cheaper than the fucking valorant knife it's still
cheaper um but oh my god i just think like they're so smart
they're so smart make the default so fucking expensive that
the consumers don't care it's it's so smart oh my god it
really is because people complain about the cost Every other
game except for Valorant and League.
And then, like, well, the characters are locked as well in
League, right?
So, like, there's, like, locked characters in League.
And then if meta changes, you might as well, like, purchase
the characters and stuff.
So they're so smart.
It's just business.
They know how to do business.
Yeah, yeah, you need to unlock them.
They just, they just really know how to do business.
okay homie thank you the super chat thank you thank you god
knows how much money i'm willing to spend for the exactly
i'm going to spend a lot of money for the funny thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you um uh league players
do complain it's like the only thing we know how to do yeah
you guys complain but you know they're not going to do
anything about it it's like what are you going to do cry at
with their hundred they're used their hundred dollar
it it's just like there'll be like good leave here i was
just gonna be like fine leave we can replace you
yeah um
the people who complain the loudest are the ones when
they're... That is so true.
That is so true.
You will be replaced.
We will do another K-pop collab and we shall replace you.
It's so true!
Like, people are complaining, drop that K-pop collab now.
Conspiracy confirmed.
works.
It just works.
So true, it hurts.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Robert, thank you.
Gaming has gone full circle to Barden.
$20 can get you an overhot skin or full of games.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Release the KDAsians.
They will be silent.
It just never fails.
and never fucking fails they don't even need to do
crossovers that's how lucrative they are they don't need to
do crossovers to actually like i mean they do like k-pop and
stuff but those aren't like actual crossover crossover
because they're original music they're like um they're like
original stuff but like other games have to do real fucking
crossovers to make people play their game that's how
powerful riot is riot marketing is so good like like
overwatch has to do like collabs with different celebrities
and different like animated stuff and like but like but like
right doesn't have to care they just make original content
and they don't have to revenue share they're like we don't
need a collab of a k-pop uh we're like we don't need a
collab with k-pop people we won't make our own k-pop and
then they did i remember there was a sienna with kda where
they replaced i think they replaced like one or the one of
the members one or two members in the KDA squad of the
original KDA squad to somebody else because they didn't want
to, I don't know what the controversy was, but they replaced
like one or two of the original singers for the original KDA
squad because of something, like it was a controversy, and
then no one cared that they got replaced.
They were just like, they were like, whoa, it's not a little
different.
You guys see Rumpur?
It was a huge thing yeah yeah I don't remember why I don't
remember the controversy they just had they replaced one of
the KDA members because of something and then because
they're like I don't know what happened but they replaced
one of them and then people were like she sounds a little
different oh well I still love KDA um mama thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you back in my league days we
used cry a lot they just need to release a new skin for us
so i'll jump on it the cycle continues on to milk us and you
shall be milked thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you it's a brutal industry um yeah it's cheap and we shall
continue to milk you
I don't think I didn't notice that Some people didn't notice
it Yeah I honestly I don't remember That's how good RIPR is
I don't remember why I don't remember why they replaced her
It's just it was like something going on And people were
like what the fuck But But just like anyway Here's some more
KDAs I'm just I'm
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How much money do I have to pay for you to get to do a song
as a KDA member?
110,000 Canadian, 1 million.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, they're so smart.
Riot marketing is just...
Riot marketing is just... Riot marketing and PR, they're
just too good.
can't believe they made a game to promote their k-pop group
i heard i heard k-pop vtubers are starting to become uh
extremely popular now i'm not i don't really follow k-pop in
general um i used to like k-pop a lot when i was like a
really a lot younger like girls generation and wonder girls
and renaism like i and oh and super junior super junior was
for those who don't know who super junior was it was the bts
of the time because i used to go to school that was like 70
percent uh korean students so i knew a lot about i knew a
lot about like k-pop back then before it was like i
basically knew k-pop before it got big in like na because i
used to um i used to go to school with like 60 to 70 percent
korean students so oh yeah oh yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry
uh Tokyo's a k-pop boomer like a super junior was uh was
like pre-bts uh she liked it before it was cool i'm a
veteran but now i don't care now i don't know anything about
k-pop i don't know anything
um um yeah i have no idea about like what the fuck is hip
now because i don't have like my korean friends to tell me
what's hip um oh my god in four minutes oh my god didn't
like four minutes to spend and people were so wait to 21 is
21 still going they had like the most creative ever 21 i
love their name i love like how they uh it's all the same
now it's all the same i think this is spanish right uh i
really i used to love the i don't know any other songs to
any yeah to anyone and then everyone call it 21 yeah oh they
separate now they're still popular solos but i don't i don't
remember any of the songs they made i just remember i just
loved it way yeah is that Is it 21?
Yeah.
21.
That's supposed to be, like, how it's pronounced.
Yeah, I was a K-pop boomer.
I don't follow K-pop anymore, though.
But, yeah, there's, like, apparently, like, K-pop V-tubers
are becoming, like, super popular.
I was reading about how, like, there's a new V-tuber boom in
Korea now.
And that's why, like, a lot of people are doing, like,
V-tuber groups based off of K-pop.
because like um there's there is a huge vtuber boom now um
in korea so that's why like people are starting like kpop
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah play is that how you pronounce it
uh it's going like crazy now over there um so that's why you
might be seeing like why a lot of like a lot of like people
are focusing on kpop now for vtubers or like a lot of people
are doing like kpop stuff or like focusing on marketing in
korea um just because like uh i think like was it play or
plav i can't i don't i've never i've only heard like one or
another song because i was curious about it um yeah it's
like you know how like the vtuber boom in na because of
covid so it's like there's like a and like there's a vtuber
boom in na like that was started because like covid and
stuff and it was like a vtuber boom um in like certain
countries and stuff like that because like certain so now
the vtuber boom is start is picking up now and starting in
korea at the moment uh because of because of the vtuber kpop
groups um and and am i pronouncing the name right play or is
it plav i can't believe doki is gonna be a kpop and also it
also helps a lot with the fact that like twitch they can't
stream on twitch anywhere so they have to stream on youtube
uh so like making music is like one of the easiest way uh
it's play v is that right play play v play v is that how you
pronounce it
um so yeah they're kpop vtubers now because it's the new
thing it's well not new thing but it's the vtuber boom now
um it also like doesn't help Oh, that BTS is still in the
army.
Um, it's still in the army.
They're still in the army.
So, like, people are looking at, like, new, I guess, like,
new substitutes for it.
And that's why, like, people have migrated to, like,
VTubers.
Um, yeah, because they're, like, the BTS VTuber now.
Yeah.
It's, um, so they're, like, the VTuber.
I guess you could call them like BTS vtubers
BTS is in the army yes that's why they're yes
wait guys were you under the rock they've been in the army
for a while now that's why a lot of kpop fans have migrated
to vtubers because they were trying to find substitute to
BTS I was like they're like BTS is in the army
Are you guys living under a fucking rock?
Yes, that's why.
I think it's like two years.
I'm pretty sure.
I think it's like around two years.
And then they're back.
This has been a minute.
It's like two to three years.
Yeah, two to three years.
So I thought I thought I was like super super interesting.
But yeah, if you guys don't know, Twitch like what I think
it was like I don't remember the whole thing.
Oh yeah, I think it was like Korea wanted to it was weird.
It's weird.
It's so complicated.
Because like Twitch didn't want to pay the extra fees or
something.
So then so they're like now we out.
Because they're like, we're losing money anyway.
So we're out.
To be fair, Twitch is always losing money.
If you guys didn't know, Twitch has not made back their
money yet.
They're still in the negatives.
So because like bandwidth and like servers, server hosting
is like crazy fucking expensive.
And Twitch is already like losing money.
And then like they, I think like the ISP wanted to charge
more to Twitch.
But then they were like, bro, we're already fucking losing
money.
Like, no.
And then they're like, and then, and then I guess like, I
guess like the ISP was like, you won't leave.
There's no way.
You need us.
And then Twitch was, Twitch like, was like, bet.
And then they left.
And then like, there was this whole thing.
There was this whole thing where like, I think like the ISP
tried to try to pursue a lawsuit against Twitch.
Yeah, what would you do?
Leave?
And then Twitch was like, okay.
Okay.
And then I think like they try to pursue a lawsuit against
Twitch But something is like, wait, you can't leave.
Here's another.
We're gonna find you if you leave and Twitch was like bye
It made a lot of it was it really sucked because it meant
like a lot of twitch streamers even like chatters to they
can't sub to their favorite streamers like a lot of like
korean uh stream like chatters or like korean um accounts on
twitch they can't even like sub or do anything i think they
can chat they can chat but they can't like uh donate
anything they can't buy anything or anything on twitch to
support their streamers so it like really sucks for like the
chatters and also like the the content creators too um so
like I know like a lot of them moved to like Africa is that
it I know like Africa YouTube cake um the like I think it's
um pretty interesting that it basically like rejuvenized um
Africa because like yeah Africa TV for those who don't know
Africa TV is it's the it's like the Korean like a Korean
equivalent to Twitch and um and like when Twitch started
more popular nobody really used africa anymore but because
of the twitch band everyone went back to africa i remember
because um because overwatch used to be like super popular
in korea and a lot of like korean streamers will use africa
um it was like completely dead and now it's like back now uh
because of twitch being kicked out of korea uh
I thought it was, like, really interesting.
It always goes back to Overwatch.
Oh, yeah.
I thought it was, like, really interesting.
The universe is quite an interesting place sometimes.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
I guess we had a super long Overwatch stream today.
So, I'm sorry I couldn't chat long.
longer oh my god bite size thank you for the 50 gifted ships
thank you thank you i really appreciate it thank you so much
holy uh but anyway guys i am gonna call it here yes over
already we we talk for like almost an hour and a half
everyone so i'm gonna rest now i always have a great time
just chatting with my dragoons um but um i hope like i hope
we hit 700k soon our first milestone official milestone i
remember i was like i hope i got 500k by the end of the year
like i'm gonna treat 700k as like our first official
milestone to hit um but thank you everybody i always have a
great time just hanging out and chatting with everyone uh
never think of this to reach out thank you thank you have a
nice rest week it's not i'm sorry it's not gonna be a rest
week unfortunately there's a lot of things going on behind
the scenes so um it's not gonna be our rest week but thank
you so much for the super chat numbers thank you thank you
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys